yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing light like Martin seen London
what is he doing here this is slowing I
think it plays the open right not sure
i'm heading ok i wanted to go for an
accelerated dragon so my DNA oh ok
Jack's a little bit unusual so Queen d7
is going to play Bishop b5 one set
dangerous they are probably not so
dangerous but certainly playable curious
but this should be 5 is kind of a given
no no don't know what else taking Wendy
seven would be extremely lame
[Music]
yeah let's just do I just kill the pawn
structure okay I could dodge rook c8 and
just make sure that I'm not getting any
back with porn sit too slow I don't
think he can seriously take them Neville
t ok so he goes back I to kill up y'all
that great right heading the night to
25c going to 53 here on domain
yeah here I was thinking night over 20
fire it's activated oh maybe I can maybe
I could have tea can only try for deform
but then look the one okay well night if
five doesn't look all that bad but I
wonder the best from something else
something better you not bad though
night to see form is nice okay so the
question is castles or taking I think
I'm taking this just going form keep it
simple plain ok so here 97 he will
probably play Queen to c7 a small
thinking Queen B 5 in this position and
maybe could be three or something anyway
I'm styling starting with this queen bee
three of the country tune
19 756 of course that can be ok he
prevents it immediately still it's a
play Queen a4 isn't that a double attack
or is it playing we need to also comes
to bring into consideration but let's do
that just take the the big pond down
[Music]
since is totally totally unfazed here
like two mara Evil Queen takes d4 ticks
ticks hook on the 17
might be yes might be a bit of a problem
and Quincy five and then taking as
definitely definitely on and maybe I
should just take this is there something
directly wrong with it I don't see it at
the moment okay this is also getting
knight c6 on the agenda what is he doing
here night and five and Quincy five said
what he wants to do I could have gone to
see sex I sure I should have actually
thought about that whole moment it would
have been a good idea protected okay
anyway
yallick is not really threatening all
that much I can use play time learning
be several texts Oh is he threatening
something Queen B seven and then I have
to play after play would be three and a
four something like that ah come on and
spoiling this position which was just
good right I had just be three of course
I wanted to go g4 but he can play b3m
that's very stupid very stupid yeah come
on plate it wins now we don't do it
extremely unnecessary play
yes it was it was an extremely simply
badly played from a position where i was
just clearly better probably winning
with good play I mean with the double
def porn and so on that was simply to
the terrible for what yeah but I'm is
played at what can you do okay still so
not sleazy
our candles over sometime what was it
fun time I can go super crazy tamiya and
just a complete idiot I mean why does
completely outside here of course losing
losing is really terrible I mean maybe
you can spoil it to a draw at losing
can't imagine so I mean ok this is the
active when I don't think it can be bad
but that's something that Queen d8 might
be good I believe that yeah but the
Queen d5 is just all so fine and now
create form is getting to have six I
take and now let's just review this
correctly I just I just plated plated
totally badly rookie aid Sam maybe this
is still ok MC ade yeah now okay night
eh four wins the game and I was really
bad I mean d3 was winning he some or
didn't play that it was a simple winner
and they've spotted it right after and
played it so g55 was awful yeah that
seems to win but this is already it
feels a little bit too complicated for
position by widest just totally busted
can i play it and somehow differently
that it's easier i mean but ok not
taking this yeah i mean it is and it is
good enough I don't need to second way
to win and it is not even threatening
stuff it's not in threatening anything
so I can can also just play this for and
cream c6 or 96
yeah why just played the opening
absolutely badly he is already already
out plate but again yeah if you don't
convert it it doesn't help should you
sell never this is very very logical
okay getting the night against bishop
scenario yeah g5 for service was bad and
yeah I'm still fires h6 here also you
shouldn't lose but by now the time was
badly may I just have to kill this off
earlier and not like here or a couple of
months ago here things are already
belly-up okay thanks for watching